We are now learning something we many of us
worried about and suspected, which is that
millions of coronavirus vaccine doses are
what The Daily Beast is describing as likely
lost in the system of vaccine distribution,
although exactly what that means when you
have such malicious players involved as Trump
himself, Jared Kushner and others is a real
question.
The Biden administration found out very quickly
when they took over that there really was
no plan for vaccine distribution.
Despite all of the claims about we've got
the best generals and logistics in all of
this different stuff, there really was no
serious plan turned over to the Biden administration
for continued distribution of vaccines.
And now it is appearing as though there are
millions of doses just missing and the answer
hasn't yet emerged.
What we know is that according to data from
the CDC at the time of The Daily Beast's report
on this, forty one point four million doses
had been handed out to states and only twenty
one point eight million had been administered.
So that means there's 20 million doses in
theory given to states, but not yet administered.
Officials say they believe there is a surplus
somewhere, but it's not clear how much of
a surplus there is, because even though you
hear those numbers, well, there must be 20
million doses sitting around.
States are saying we're out of vaccines.
We don't know we don't know where these numbers
are coming from, but we don't have vaccines
sitting around.
We're giving out doses in some cases almost
as quickly as they come in.
So Biden's coronavirus task force members
went back and looked at the numbers again.
They looked at local data.
They looked at federal data.
Here's what federal data says was given to
states.
Here's what local data says they have.
And they looked at, is it a manufacturing
problem?
Is it a shipping problem?
Is it a receiving problem?
Is it a waiting around to be administered
problem?
What's in warehouses, what's in hospitals,
for example?
They can't figure out what's going on.
And every data set that they look at is missing
something.
And then when they look at a data set from
a different source, it sort of overlaps.
But it's inconsistent.
It's incongruent.
And what they've what they've chalked it up
to so far are what they are calling, quote,
incredible inefficiencies.
And I have to tell you that my suspicions,
my fears, I think is better said, ah, that
this is significantly worse than that.
Were their lies told about availability by
the Trump administration?
Right.
And so what they claimed to have sent to states,
they didn't because there weren't actually
the numbers available that they claimed that
would be maybe incompetence and dishonesty,
but not criminality.
The other fear, of course, is were some of
these doses delivered to the federal government
and then something was done with them?
I'm not saying Jared Kushner is selling doses
to who knows where.
At least I don't have evidence of that at
this point in time.
But is there some kind of skimming that has
been taking place at this point?
Everything is on the table because the numbers
just don't make sense.
The numbers just don't add up.
And right now, Biden administration officials
are taking the point of view that based on
what they know right now, it seems to be a
combination of shipping delays and kinks in
reporting.
So that here's an here's like the most benign
possible example.
I'm making these numbers up.
Texas gets 10 million doses on paper.
Federal government says we gave you 10 million
doses.
Texas gets them and then sends them right
back out to hospitals and hospitals, get the
10 million doses.
But it takes them a while to report on the
number administered.
So a hospital gets 100000 and they administer
80000 and they don't yet report that they've
administered the eighty thousand.
They just say, listen, we only see 20000 available
doses.
The 80000 that were administered haven't yet
been reported as administered.
That would be like the most benign explanation
on the other side of it are really, really
horrible hypotheses about wrongdoing, malfeasance,
falsification of orders, skimming and all
sorts of things that seem very.
Jared Kushner, if you're familiar with his
track record as a landlord in New York City
in the New York City area, the other possibility
is that they didn't steal anything.
But things have been lost or things have been
spoiled and they didn't want to come clean
about spoilage.
We.
Anecdotally of stories about a pharmacist
in I don't remember what state, maybe Wisconsin
or Michigan deliberately spoiled some doses
because he's some kind of anti boxer and he's
been charged.
We know about some number of doses, that cleaning,
I think it was in Boston, a cleaning person
accidentally unplugged one of the freezers
that are used and a bunch of vaccines spoiled.
And those there are reports of maybe there's
some bigger spoilage issue or loss issue and
it's not it's not being reported.
I don't know.
What it increasingly does seem like, though,
is that it's not that there are just millions
of doses sitting under a table somewhere.
And any day now we're going to find them and
say, oh, the numbers all add up perfectly
with every day that passes without answers
to what's going on.
The idea that they're just going to find these
becomes less and less likely.
So, you know, I'm not saying check the freezers
at Mar a Lago, but when it comes to the Trump
administration and the dishonesty I wouldn't
put anything past them is the point.
And hopefully at some point we're going to
get some answers about what happened here.
The good news is and if you watched yesterday's
Joe Biden press event with me, you saw Joe
Biden say that they are going to be upping
vaccine distribution from eight point six
million doses a week to 10 million doses a
week.
That's going to get us closer, not quite to
one point five million per day, but in the
one point two million area, we have the JMJ
one dose vaccine that is supposedly just a
week or so from presenting data to the CDC
and hopefully will get approval there.
It is plausible and hopefully increasingly
likely that Joe Biden is right in what he
said yesterday, that during spring, anyone
who wants the vaccine will be able to get
one.
We're going to follow it.
We've been following it and I'll keep you
posted.
As far as
that goes,